foreign
episode got taken down and we got
strikes on YouTube and we couldn't post
for a week those were the rules there
are other places you know we might start
uploading the show to Twitter we were
experimenting with all kinds of things
you don't get to communicate with
YouTube really about it right they kind
of this ruling comes from people you
can't communicate with or access and
then that's how they do it he's like wow
we could just cut the joke out and I'm
like I'm not just taking a three minute
chunk out of my special Joe list just
got done celebrating the release of his
third stand-up special in the last three
years but festivities were cut short
just 12 days later when YouTube struck
his video with various restrictions
demonetizing the video and stopping all
the built up momentum this special had
when the news first came out that Joe
special was being suppressed I was
confused as someone who watched enough
for everybody in its entirety I was
racking my brain trying to think of what
part could have possibly gotten this
thing flat as it turns out Joe list was
struck for using the word as the punch
line in one of his favorite jokes of the
new hour although the whole thing is
very funny start to finish which is why
it's even a bigger shame that YouTube is
making it so hard for people to see
that's what's ironic by the way the the
the the the seaward joke is like uh
Progressive I'm saying we used to treat
women shittily right they don't it's no
Nuance it's all some robot who hurt and
malfunction exactly so yeah Gianna said
the great point he's like people are
looking at their screen so much they're
becoming AI That's why like like that
New York Times thing you commented they
didn't get the joke it's almost the
irony we're losing our Nuance right
right we're becoming robots that's a
good point they're flagged or whatever
you call strike whatever they call that
yes yes God hates Flags they just hear
the word and go like bad yeah right yeah
there's no uh Nuance or irony or context
just word based yeah so now and then I
was talking to my associate over there
you do and he's like well could just cut
the joke out and I'm like I'm not just
taking a three minute chunk out of my
special no it's a good joke bleep it if
anything but can you go in and go
well maybe but we've already
appealed once so now it's like we have
to appeal a second time now something
that makes YouTube's behavior during
this entire situation even more
interesting is comparing the current
landscape of comedy on YouTube to that
of corporate streamers in which YouTube
was originally used to break free from
what once was thought of as an enemy of
real comedy due to its typical
mainstream censorship and fear of
backlash from jokes Netflix and YouTube
have completely switched places it used
to seem like the corporate route was
where you go to cash a check with the
understanding that they might cut out
any jokes they deem inappropriate while
YouTube was the Wild West that allowed
free speech and trusted their viewers to
think critically on their own but
nowadays YouTube is the one suppressing
specials for edgy jokes while Netflix is
the one supporting real comedy they
allowed Shane Gillis to do hilarious
jokes about Isis Trump Biden gaze you
name it everything was on the table for
him with Netflix and Netflix I gotta
hand it to him they let me say
everything yeah I figured you with the r
word that was over the big tardo and uh
they were like I go nuts well here's the
thing it's back yeah
time to let them know again
they know they're oh they sure do
Netflix choosing to once again Champion
comedians is obviously good news in the
grand scheme but really doesn't help
fill the huge gap that will be left by
YouTube if they no longer support comedy
Netflix is still a gate kept system in a
lot of ways just because they're willing
to support dark humor doesn't mean just
anybody can release a special on their
platform and that was always the beauty
of YouTube in the first place so many of
the best modern day Comics like Mark
Shane Joe and more blew up by
self-producing projects on their own and
uploading them to YouTube for free fans
can see their hard work start buying
tickets to their shows joining their
patreons it's been the new way young
comedians can make a name in this
industry and it just sucks that we could
potentially be missing out on the next
Mark Norman because of these illogical
rules it seems like comedians have
different experiences working with like
these big streamers obviously like
Andrew Schultz had the story about
buying his back and you're someone who
typically works with darker jokes and
darker topics so was there anything that
Netflix had a problem with or were they
just like the keys are in your hands I
couldn't believe it I think maybe like a
Dave Chappelle or somebody opened the
door for uh just saying crazy or
Ricky Gervais maybe they were cool with
I got Holocaust Down syndrome you know
fat jokes trans jokes you name it and
they were the only thing they said was I
wouldn't do covet stuff just because
it's it's passed yeah it's out of date
so I was like great it's not just
uploading full-length specials that's
giving comedians trouble even podcasts
now rely heavily on this platform to
share their episodes which means the
funniest people who push boundaries more
often and take the biggest risks are
having the most trouble Tim Dillon has
been aggressively suppressed times and
theovan has had passed and current
episodes completely removed I don't know
Stavros was having this problem he did
an episode with Santino that was in it I
think they demonetized that or took it
and it had like a hundred thousand views
in one day and now it has a hundred and
ten thousand oh my God and so that's
what I'm looking at right now this
happened to me with Glassman I did Rick
Glassman so we usually have a pretty
good rapport and he was like this is
gonna get 250 easy and we got about a
hundred and five because I think I said
something offensive yeah it's really
horrible and I think Tuesday's with
stories has been demonetized it's not
good because YouTube used to be the
place to be and now it's gonna be some
new new Young Bucks gonna come out we're
all gonna move to a funner neighborhood
we can upload straight to Twitter the
whole episodes now yeah that guy that's
true yeah I mean that's what the ovonne
did and he got like eight million views
on it because everyone has to see it now
his Roseanne episode got taken away
because Roseanne said some Holocaust
and then they he goes well it
and he went he tweeted about it Elon
Musk tweeted back and said Put it on
here and just all the buzz got eight
million views wow so it actually did
better until some changes start to
happen higher up in the YouTube
corporate ladder there's a few solutions
that comedians have been able to utilize
in the face of suppression kind of when
Matt Rife had his hour special Matthew
Stephen Rife age restricted out of
nowhere he chose to delete and re-upload
the video but turned to censorship into
a viral marketing call to action and the
special ended up hitting great numbers a
second time around another case of
flipping this issue on its head and
using it for your own gain is a story
that everyone's familiar with by now
related to Andrew Schultz and Infamous
maybe I'll be one of these guys you know
like these uh scriptures well the people
that are like they got me right you know
help me out or whatever yeah you'll be
at the Capitol in the air because
Schultz I mean he blew up because he he
was on Barry Weiss because he had to
change something or something yeah yeah
too offensive some streamer wouldn't
have them whatever the story is but he
made a cool five mil I do think you
should throw it up on Twitter as well
it the whole special yeah nothing
but the special I mean oh my God
I do but uh I think you know you you
throw it up on Twitter because the
theopod's an hour and 40. this is an
hour right interesting okay maybe I'll
do it Twitter's been the solution thrown
out by a few guys now especially after
seeing the viral success that Theo Von
had posting his band episode with
Roseanne which received over 80 million
views Twitter sounds great in theory and
is a good option to get some more
eyeballs but you can't rely on Elon Musk
to retweet every single episode and I
feel like more people go on Twitter
seeking short form quick hitting
entertainment it might be harder to reel
someone into watching an hour and 40
Minute Podcast when they just open the
app to read a few quick tweets which
again is what's so beautiful about
YouTube people come on here with open
minds looking for high quality videos to
sink their teeth into of any length it's
still unclear what the solution to all
of this is gonna be in the end but if it
is just wild and bizarre that we're
living in the year 2023 and still
struggling for freedom of speech online
however all of us can help do something
right now by going over to Joe List's
YouTube channel and watching his
full-length special enough for everybody
guest spots from last week The Joe Rogan
Experience had a protect our Parks Louis
J Gomez and a fight companion two bears
one cave was with Bert and Tom Tom and
Bert kill Tony this weekend on Roseanne
Barr and David kochner flagrant did not
have a guest we might be drunk out on
salvokano Sal was also the guest in are
you garbage Matt and Shane's secret
podcast talked with Billy Moses storm
was on the Honeydew taste buds was Sal
and Eric Andre Nickie Glazer was a guest
on Whiskey Ginger and why Mage had on
are you garbage the Oz it's working any
side effects yeah
what is it the main one yeah is the
burps burps buddy dude I figured this
was the place to talk about it yes yeah
genuinely the worst thing I've ever
smelled in my life so I'm not even
joking dude we were on the plane
yesterday or the other day we sat
together and I had it really bad and it
just it's literally like you're burping
up rotten eggs
we get on the plane this is my best
friend and the wife we spend like every
day together and typically if there's a
smell
you know what I mean it's like I know
what it is if he hasn't showered or
whatever you're like I know all your
stuff exactly so we're sitting there
we're on the plane and you know we're
right by the bathroom in the front and
uh the bathroom there was something
wrong with it in the beginning like oh
we're waiting on pressure or something
so they were like it's not really
working right now that's the worst so
then we're sitting there dude and it
smells like a we're like even pranking
these things out like every couple of
minutes but you're doing like those
kindly I'm doing this I'm doing the I'm
doing the you know the fat girl at a bar
you know what I'm talking about this
past weekend with Yvonne did not have a
guest the Tim Dillon show talked with
RFK Jr and Cheryl Hines the Box podcast
had on Stevo Johnny Mitchell was on
first date take your shoes off with Rick
Glassman had on Kyle Dunnigan JoJo Rosa
was on you know what dude Mike Cannon
was a guest on Chrissy chaos tigerbelly
had on Mateo Lane Too Short was on this
podcast Joe list was on only fiens
and there's a new episode of the rags
that was uploaded last week as well
before we move on to new specials a
quick word from today's sponsor mybookie
football season is finally back and my
bookie has a new cash out system that
allows you to bet and win all season
long I know you guys are going to be
betting on these games so you might as
well be using my bookie for an entire
season filled with odd boost and free
bets they're one of the most trusted and
easy to use Platforms in the game and is
my preferred way to bet every single
Sunday this season my bookie has a no
strings attached Cash Out bonus that
lets you deposit and withdraw quickly
use our promo code jkwrld on deposits of
50 or more and you could receive up to
200 in cash bonuses bet your deposit
amount once and you can cash out anytime
again that's promo code jkwrld to claim
your cash out bonus you can bet anything
anytime anywhere only with mybookie now
back to the video as far as new stand-up
specials are either out right now or
coming out soon by far one of the
biggest specials of the Year Shane
Gillis beautiful dogs is out right now
on Netflix and currently trending number
one in the United States Louis J Gomez
also released a special last week called
30 minutes with Louis J Gomez followed
by 30 minutes with column Tyrell that
came out this week a few years ago
Donald Trump was in the news and he was
in trouble what he did was he put a load
of
undocumented migrants in cages a lot of
those people were kids and nearly
everyone was like yo this is messed up
you can't put kids in cages some people
were like
that's what you get
but most people are like this is
up and then Joe Biden was like yo put me
in charge I'll free these kids and then
he ran for a president and he won and he
became president of the United States of
America and then
he uh
I think he forgot has anyone
it's not even checked on those kids
they're all in their 20s now
too big for those little kid-sized cages
just waiting Mr yo
Presidente Biden please and Mr yo
there's also a few specials that will be
coming out relatively soon Matt Rife is
preparing to film his next special
titled natural selection taping will
take place next weekend in Washington DC
and the special will come out on Netflix
later this year please let me know in
the comments if there's any upcoming
specials that we missed in this week's
episode of The Comedy news which is also
available right now for download on
Apple podcasts and Spotify we also have
a handful of videos that will be coming
out later this week right here on joke
world so if you enjoy comedy and want to
stay in the loop with all your favorite
comedians please consider subscribing to
this Channel right now thanks for
watching
at joke world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out